في المقابل قال رئيس مجلس الدوما الروسي
فيات سلاف فولودين ان تزويده اوكرانيا
باسلحه هجوميه سيؤدي الى كارثه عالميه
وحذر المسؤول الروسي والدول الغربيه وعلى
راسها الولايات المتحده من ان هذا توجهها
سيقود الى اجراءات الانتقاميه باسلحه اقوى
على حد تعبيره
تامر وجديد المعارك لاسيه ما
فيا وفي الجبهه الجنوبيه
بالفعل وسيله كانت هنالك تصريحات خلال
الدقائق الاخيره لافته صح التعبير
للمتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في سوبر
روجيا وفي خرسون ايضا وقال بان حده
المعارك حده العمليات
الهجوميه التي تقوم بها القوات الروسيه في
زبرجه تحديدا تراجعت الى مستويات متدنيه
خلال الساعات الماضيه وقال بان القوات
الاوكرانيه تمكنت بالفعل خلال الساعات
الماضيه من استعاده المواقع التي كانت
بحوزتها والتي سقطت بشكل مؤقت كما قال في
قبضه القوات الروسيه نتيجه القصف المدفعي
المكثف بالمدفعيه الثقيله المتواصل من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه المتحدث العسكري
الاوكراني يقول الان بان كافه المواقع
الاوكرانيه التي سقطت خلال همم يوم امس
واليوم باتت في قبضه القوات الاوكرانيه من
جديد ويقول بان ال- ال- الح للان في
زبروجه يقتصر فقط على عمليات صغيره لبعض
المجموعات الصغيره الاستطلاعيه التي تحاول
ان تتقدم باتجاه بعض المواقع التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الاوكرانيه لكن هذه
المحاولات تقابل برد عنيف من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه هذا ما يخص جبروجيه لكن ايضا
فيزا بروجي ايضا تحديدا في محيط محطه
زبروجه للطاقه النوويه تقول السلطات
المحليه هناك بان القوات الروسيه ترسل
مزيد من التعزيزات الى محيط
المحطه وتحذر من تفاقم الوضع هناك وايضا
الاداره العسكريه خلال الساعه الاخيره فقط
تحدثت عن استمرار القصف همم الروسي باتجاه
المناطق المدنيه وتحدثت عن اكثر من 170
قضيه سقطت على مناطق ماهوله بالسكان هذا
ما يخص جبروجه لكن هنا في خير سون الجبهه
مستمرات تت عدوى القصف في تحديدا الروسي
على العديد من المواقع السكنيه الاسيه ما
عند القرى والبلدات الواقعه على ضفتين
هاردينيبر هنالك مواجهه مفتوحه بين
الطرفين القوات الاوكرانيه تقول بانها
تكثف بالمدفعيه الثقيله لقصفها للمواقع
الروسيه على الضفه الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر
وتتحدث القوات الاوكرانيه بان القوات هناك
تعزز من تواجدها بطبيعه الحال الحديث عن
القوات الروسيه بالاضافه الى مزيد من
الاجراءات الاحترازيه كما تسميها تخوفا من
تقدم او مزيد من التقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه
باتجاه بعض المناطق او المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها او يسيطر عليها الجانب الروسي على
الضفه الشرقيه من النهار في الحقيقه نحن
كنا يوم امس عند نقطه متقدمه من خطوط
القتال بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
والرصدنا كثافه ناريه للقوات الاوكرانيه
باتجاه المواقع الروسيه وهنالك استخدام
واسع للمدفعيه ذاتيه الدفع التي تقوم
القوات الاوكرانيه باستخدامها للرد ولي
قصف المواقع التي تتمركز فيها القوات
الروسيه هناك والقصف ايضا وفقا للقوات
الاوكرانيه يتواصل على مقاطعه ميكولايب
الجنوبيه تقريبا
عن المواقع الساحليه الاساسيه من منطقه
اوتشاكو نعم